hello everyone and welcome to another uh
a very exciting and very short game uh
from round five of the vhs olympiads
2022 it's not rebecca satorov uh who uh
defeated fabiano corona yesterday and is
on a perfect score against uh slovakia
slovakia's youngest grandmaster 20 year
old yergus perhaps who
who who became basically their youngest
grandmaster in 2019
and there's also a fun story regarding
him during the
uh qualifier last year for the for the
feeling world cup uh boris girlfriend
blundered a queen against him but due to
a mouse slip and then he immediately
offered a draw so obviously uh we are
dealing with a true gentleman here and
now that being said let's check out the
game as uh it's uh it is just incredible
how simple this game is and you know
that it can happen uh with two grand
masters playing uh so let's uh see what
happened abdusatrov has the white pieces
and he opens with e4
sorry about that
uh we have e5 by perhaps a knight to f3
knights to c6 and bishop to b5 the rule
lopez is on the board and now usually uh
like 99 percent of the times you will
see morphe's defense or the berlin
defense but very very rarely incredibly
rarely indeed will you see the cause
your defense with knight the g to e7 and
this is what uh perhaps prepared as uh
as a surprise for abdul sator of we have
castles and now ponte g6 pawn to d4 uh
striking in the center going after that
the uh sorry i'm going after the d5 pawn
e captures knight captures and bishop g7
knight captures on c6 we have b captures
in c6 bishop to a4 and here we have
castles knight to c3 rook to b8 and now
there is a game where queen to f3 was
played but here rook to one and it is
now already as of move tender we have a
completely new game so what uh is
happening here uh well not all that much
black has uh a double c pawn but he does
have the same open file for his rook and
he will have additional support for
executing d5 when he
chooses to do so so the sixth first we
have bishop to b3 now the dark square
bishop can be developed or a b2 pawn
will not be hanging and now bishop to e6
offering a trade of light square bishops
we have knights to e2 uh preparing to go
knight to f4 to put pressure on the
bishop here and pawn to c5 now
taking control over the d4 square but
also maybe with some ideas of shifting
the bishop over to this diagonal
and uh well after after another x next
move we are about to see will this be
the case so knight to f4 attacking the
bishop and now not knight uh not bishop
to d7 going after the c6 idea but rather
bishop captures on b3 we have eight
captures on b3 now opening up the light
uh the
uh this a file for the rook knight to c6
now defending the pawn and pawn to c3
we have a5 the pawn is nicely defended
by the knight also this rook will go to
a8 so the knight can move knight to d5
beautiful square for the knight here and
rook to a8 and here just rook to a4
now you can develop the bishop you can
maybe put the queen to a1 you can put
more pressure on this uh
uh
a a5 pawn and at some point it might be
a
problem for black to defend this for
example if you if you double up or
triple up on the a file uh maybe you can
play b4 and that's basically it so here
we have knight to e5 uh and now bishop
to f4 we have rook to e8 developing the
rook and now a move that if you were
playing this position you probably never
would have played but here bishop
captures on e5 uh just giving up the the
the i mean the knight is also strong but
it's a very rare that you will see
something like this just capturing that
knight as the knight is on a beautiful
square e5 it's almost a monster night so
uh that's why abu satrov eliminates it
bishop captures and now knight to e3
shifting the knight to c4 to go after
this a5 pawn we have a queen to b8 and
now queen to c2 pawn to c6 and now pawn
to g3 preparing f4 and here black should
probably play h5 uh to kind of
discourage white from over extending the
pawns in front of the white king but
here we have queen to b5 and now comes
knight to c4
now just attacking the a5 pawn putting
pressure on the bishop here rook eat the
b8 now attacking the
the b3 pawn saying okay you can kick
away my bishop win the d6 pawn i'm gonna
win the b3 pawn but now pawn to f4 we
have bishop to f6 and now just knight
captures on d6 queen capture some b3
queen captures rook captures on b3 so we
just trade the stuff nothing
happening here really but not knight to
c4 and it was in this position on move
27 that iair gospel resigned the game
as there seems to be nothing more that
he can do here so
truly truly an incredible game and now
uh when you look at the position and you
know that he resigned here you of course
know that black's position is completely
helpless and it is definitely
objectively so
we are going to show why of course
because it seems like there's still so
much for black to do but uh the fact of
the matter is there really isn't uh
there's no move you can make with black
you have to keep this rook here to
defend the pawn otherwise you're gonna
lose this pawn this rook has nothing to
do with the b2 pawn nicely defended uh
the bishop completely helpless against
the knight uh the the the pawn is coming
to e5 also you can
just grab the d file for yourself so
what you could do let's say you try
something like bishop d8 to add more
defenders to the a5 pawn we're going to
play rook d1 i put pressure on the d
file uh rook to be uh rook to b7 as we
have to play something you can try and
uh activated this rook but now rook to
d6 now we go after this spawn so the
double pawn really is up is a problem
here we have rook to e7 let's say going
after this pawn now e5 we just uh defend
the romp rook to e6 now defend the c6
pawn but now we can even trade rook
captures f captures and now now only now
that you've prepared everything now you
win the game by simply playing b4
and there's nothing black can do about
this you can capture once but that's it
next move you're getting a pass pawn and
it's just winning let's say king f7 b
captures on a5 you can bring the king
into the game a6 king to b7 now white
can also start bringing the king into
the game king to c7 king to e3 bishop to
e7 or something king the d4 rook to a7
and it seems like you have blockaded the
position but a simple knight to d6 and
there's no way
that you can play this there's really
nothing for you to do if you try going
uh with the king
to b6 then we can just play a knight to
c8 with check and pick up the rook here
or even if you pick up the knight here
and win the pawn it still doesn't matter
because white's position is just that
good let's say king c4 now we waste a
few moves h6 h4 h5 rook to a1 and now
black has to move either the king or the
rook let's say king to c7 now we bring
the king into the game
and
there's nothing you can do here you
can't go here you can't go here you can
move the king to d7 to keep an eye on
your pawn but now king b6 or you move
the king somewhere else and not
defending the six exponent and we just
pick up the c6 pawn
and after let's say rook to a8 king to
b7 and now black resigns there are no
more moves so it seems like there is uh
there's quite a lot to do here but there
there is in fact nothing to do here both
of them know this and that is why a
yarush perhaps resigned to the game here
and another brilliant victory for notre
dame abdusarov his fifth win in a row uh
which uh which is a really incredible
especially since he defeated fabiano
corona in the previous round with the
black pieces if you haven't seen it do
check it out it's one of my previous
videos
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it another uh effortless win
only 27 moves by the world rapid
champion not rebecca sato if you guys
said that you would like to see more
games by him so here is one i mean this
is a master class
hope you enjoyed this
uh so yeah i would like to thank david
kimura esmondalden jacob tobias derek
king and felix daffo for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad until it finishes so thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day